la russie toujours avec la justice qui
maintient l'emprisonnement alexeï
navalni l'opposant faisait appel de sa
condamnation à 2 ans et 8 mois de prison
le 2 février est notamment accusé
d'avoir violé les condamnations de sa
libération conditionnelle en poser en
2014 suite à des accusations de
détournement de fonds alexeï navalni
reconnu coupable également aujourd'hui
par un tribunal russe de diffamation
dans une autre affaire concernant un
ancien combattant de la seconde guerre
mondiale la correspondance à moscou
signée vera gosses mal
la justice russe a confirmé que la peine
de prison avec sursis prononcée contre
alexis navale et en 2014 était
transformée en cinq ans ferme
du fait de multiples violation de son
contrôle judiciaire
le tribunal a toutefois légèrement
réduit d'un mois et demi sa condamnation
et le posant devra finalement purger une
peine de deux ans et demi de prison
les avocats d'alexiane havane et vont
faire appel de cette décision auprès de
la cour de cassation
je vous propose d'écouter si les
arguments de la cod h avait été acceptée
ils auraient déjà été libérés
il serait ici avec nous envisagez-vous
de faire appel de la décision auprès
d'une cour supérieure bien sûr nous
ferons appel de la décision auprès de la
cour de cassation quand avanies
sera-t-il transféré y at il des
informations à cet égard on ne sait pas
en théorie il aurait pu être transféré
avant cette décision
on peut le faire aujourd'hui ou demain
on peut attendre l'appel dans le cadre
du procès en diffamation
ils ont les mains libres on ignore
quelle option ils choisiront je rappelle
que le pose aux russes avaient été
interpellés lors de son retour en russie
le 17 janvier comme l'avaient annoncé
les en amont les autorités russes puis
incarcéré pour 30 jours
alexeï navalni ne s'étaient pas
présentés à l'enregistrement auprès de
l'inspection pénitentiaire en moins six
reprises au cours de l'année 2020 il
s'agit de la période
avant son empoisonnement présumé en août
en ce qui concerne la condamnation de
alex est 9e n'est avait été jugé
coupable de détournement de fonds dans
la filiale russe du groupe français yves
rocher vient entreprises de transport
qu'il détenait avec son frère au legs la
réaction des avocats d'alexa une avanie
environnement tendre réaction également
du porte parole du kremlin dmitri peskov
nous avons déjà dit que la vie politique
en russie était très multiforme a les
traits multiforme
je peux accepter l'avis concernant les
opposants principaux mineurs du kremlin
en principe la scène politique russe se
caractérise par un niveau suffisant de
pluralisme
nombreux sont ceux qui s'opposent au
kremlin certains le font dans le respect
des lois
d'autres dépasse la décence certains le
font depuis le sol russe
d'autres en appuyant un ou deux pieds
sur le sol étranger
chacun à sa manière mais je répète une
fois de plus il y a beaucoup de gens qui
s'opposent au kremlin
ce qui constitue un processus politique
normal disent qu'ils préfèrent